[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jacques myard maison mais sa maison mère
a fait l air de maisons laffitte bonsoir
jacques avenir merci beaucoup d'être
avec mon ce soir sur ce plateau monique
d'abba porte parole de lutte ouvrière
bonsoir à vous monique d'abba et merci
d'être avec nous donc trois ans on a dix
jours pour jour après la première
mobilisation des gilets jaunes qu'est ce
qui reste selon-vous monique d'abba de
ce mouvement avec un certain recul
d'aujourd'hui évidemment ce qui reste
est en tout cas ce qu on entend surtout
c'est c'est que ça a eu lieu c'est que
des baies des centaines de milliers de
gens dont on n'entendait pas parler
avant et qui qui se prenait pas qu'ils
se mettaient pas en avant parce que
c'était des pauvres c'était des gens qui
avaient pas les moyens de devenir à la
télé de ce rang tente de se faire voir
et pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps ces gens là il était capable
de dire qu'ils en avaient marre et de
prendre là du coup l'antenne et de se
faire des sphères entendent vraiment
jacques myard pour vous c'est le seul
héritage d'avoir donné la parole à ces
personnes est ce qu'il ya eu pour voir
véritable impact de ce mouvement dans la
société française et un peu
mais dès que la balle passe commande je
crois que c'est pas du passé c'est
quelque chose qui est ancré aujourd'hui
dans la société qui marque les ruptures
dans notre société et la précarité d'un
certain nombre de concitoyens qui pour
moi n'est pas acceptable parce que
aujourd'hui le vote reportage était très
intéressant parce que cet homme disait
du fond du coeur ce qu'il ressentait à
savoir que
il est battu sur le plan social et qu'il
n'a pas admis les décisions
technocratiques du pouvoir d'en haut et
je crois que c'est ce que ça démontre
parce que il y a eu de la part du
gouvernement dont on a dit qu'il était
le jupiter une méprise total sur l'état
du pays
or lorsqu'on prend des décisions il faut
regarder quel est l'état le social du
pays cet état social aujourd'hui
malheureusement n'a pas changé et cela
traduit bien sûr les fractions les
ruptures de la société française que qui
doit être qu'ils doivent être réparés
donc il faut pas quoi que ce mouvement
c'est du passé non ce mouvement
peut-être ne sera pas aussi ample que
nous l'avons constaté mais il traduit
une profonde rupture dans le lien social
de la nation qui sort qui est qu'ils
sont inquiétantes alors oui à lui
valence est parvenu trouve intéressant
que salaires soutiennent le mouvement
des légers les jaunes et donc
effectivement nous nous l'avons soutenu
aussi même si si on pense qu'il aurait
pu aller plus loin et avoir beaucoup
plus d'impact sur sur la société si et
sur la demande de départ qui était celle
de l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
s'il avait pu gagner les entreprises et
les ouvriers les travailleurs dans les
grandes entreprises en particulier parce
que là où vraiment ce mouvement là pour
pour avoir de la force c'est ça sera par
les grèves massives et en s'en prenant
au profit du grand patronat là où il est
fait dans ces entreprises là
effectivement s'il y avait pu avoir une
contamination de semoule ce mouvement là
dans l'est dans les grandes entreprises
saurait changer complètement
la fin c'est la profondeur de ce
mouvement jacques maire je vous donne la
parole dont oui dans quelle que soit la
saisie et les i parce que je voulais
vous vous lire un premier message
télégramme et je voulais rebondir sur ce
que nous dira moennig là bas il s'agit
pas de soutenir mais quand on est au
gouvernement il s'agit de prendre en
compte ce qui se passe dans le pays et
là où le gouvernement a fait une faute
capitale qui a provoqué tous ces
désordres c'est qu'il était aveugle et
qu'il était sourd et donc le goût il
s'agit parfois non pas parfois mais
toujours pour un gouvernement de prendre
en compte ces revendications sociales et
d'essayer bien sûr d'y répondre parce
que lorsqu'on sait que dans notre pays
nous avons eu millions de peaux
permettez moi de rire que moi qui suis
de droite mais qui veut une droite
populaire et qui s'occupe des places
précaires et des classes moyennes
ce n'est pas acceptable et je ne peux
pas me satisfaire
qu'il y ait dans notre pays li millions
de pauvres
donc il faut mener une politique une
politique des revenus qui permet à
chacun de vivre par son travail quand il
en a et quand on est chômeur de donner
du travail qui est le lien social par
excellence donc modique là bas vous
n'avez pas le monopole je dirais de la
prof sociale et de la proche responsable
dans le gouvernement
mais là où je vais peut-être vous
rejoindrez vous dansez étonné c'est
qu'il est tout à fait légitime que c'est
peu et c'est cette révolte soit
canalisée et qu'elle ne puisse pas être
une jacquerie à ce qu' il faut
construire et pour construire on est
dans le même pays on est dans la même
barque et et je suis de ceux qui pensent
qu effectivement le vendeur et je pèse
mes mots le veau d'or a perverti parfois
la vision d'un certain nombre de gens
qu'on est des gens riches pourquoi pas
mais il n'est pas admissible qui
viennent tant de gens qui sont laissés
sur le côté justement à propos de
richesse stéphanie dino 10 à 2 euros le
litre du carburant il faut être riche
pour faire un plein pour aller bosser au
smic alors c'était justement la question
que j'avais envie de vous poser à tous
les vous dites ya beaucoup de colère
dans le pays vous dit le pouvoir d'achat
et bien c'est pas ça beaucoup de pauvres
là la crise est loin d'être terminée
puisque le prix à la pompe est au plus
haut c'est ce qui avait déclenché la
colère il ya trois ans et finalement
c'est vrai qu'on n'entend pas trop enfin
voilà c'est pas parce que il n'y a pas
de manifestation dans les rues mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'y en a pas on les
entend plus est ces français en colère
comment vous vous l'expliqué monique
d'abba moi que j'en entends c'est qu'ils
peuvent plus faire le plein d'essence
qui vont travailler à pied parce qu'ils
peuvent plus remplir le réservoir des
gens qui sont vraiment en colère de ça
j'en entends et on a d'autant plus de
raisons d'être en colère quand on voit
quand même total café 4,6 milliards de
bénéfices rien qu'au troisième trimestre
c'est avec d'un côté on a des gens qui
ne s'en sortent plus qu'ils peuvent plus
payer le chômage qui peuvent plus
même maintenant ça va gagner les prix
aussi dans les supermarchés partout
l'inflation en mai mais sur l'inflation
d'un côté ils sont coincés ils
n'arrivent plus à payer leurs leur plein
d'essence et de l'autre côté on voit
total avec des milliards pareil et là le
gouvernement ou ou même les républicains
quand c'est qu'ils disent qu'il faut
prendre sur les milliards de totals pour
pur et dur cette inflation moi j'ai pas
entendu ça alors jacques myard oui alors
qu'il y ait des distributions de
dividendes à outrance ça pose le
problème effectivement je dirais de l'
équilibre dans la politique des revenus
des gens et des autres que les
actionnaires je voudrais vous poser une
question parce que là on va partir dans
un débat qui est pas celui de base
justement je reviens à la même question
pardonnez-moi sur sur la flambée sociale
ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya pas de gens
dans la rue qui a pas de colère mais
tout de même on sent que c'est
relativement maîtrisé est-ce que tout de
même emmanuel macron ont fait des gestes
notamment le bouclier tarifaire sur le
gaz et l'électricité le chèque carburant
le chômage partiel pendant le coc vide
dans le chômage parce qu'elle est exact
a permis à certaines entreprises et à
certains salariés d'être payés très bien
c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte mais il
n'en demeure pas moins que il faut que
ce pays retrouve une politique des
revenus et que effectivement on constate
que ce soit dans la fonction publique où
que ce soit dans celle des salariés
qu'il y a eu des blocages de salaire qui
ne peut pas continuer donc il faut que
dans les entreprises d'une manière
générale on retrouve une politique des
revenus car le risque est effectivement
du ras-le-bol et je comprends alors dans
l'histoire de l'augmentation du pétrole
et de l'essence à la pompe il y à des
facteurs internationaux qui je l'espère
ne dureront pas mais c'est certain que
aujourd'hui nous avons des concitoyens
qui souffrent qui n'arrivent pas ou qui
me le disait coluche la fin du mois à
cette occasion du mois et ça ce n'est
pas acceptable
on a vu le gouvernement donner une prime
qu'il reprenait de l'autre par les taxes
on sait bien que ce prix de l'essence ce
sont des taxes qui font que le prix est
élevé est ce qu'il y a la marge des
pétroliers au regard de du pétrole
qu'ils achètent sur le marché
international est quand même très limité
donc c'est une question de taxation mais
là le gouvernement ne veut pas faire
baisser ses taxes par crainte par
crainte que ça puisse entraîner d'autres
facteurs par ailleurs mais je crains
fort que il est dans une impasse
sur wii sur les salaires c'est aucun
gouvernement n'imposera a aucune
entreprise d'augmenter les salaires les
augmentations de salaire et sont
indispensables sont nécessaires on s'en
sort plus avec les salaires qu'on touche
dans les entreprises mais ces
augmentations faudra les arracher au
patronat ça va aider des grèves ça va
être des bagarres durées longues parce
qu'aucun gouvernement c'est pas vrai ne
donnera là ne m'imposera quoi que ce
soit aux entreprises parce que de toute
façon les entreprises font ce qu'elles
veulent c'est elle qui décide que macron
leur donne des milliards qui efface tout
ce qu'elles veulent avec ça c'est ce
qu'elle demande et c'est ce qu'ils
attendent du gouvernement mais jamais n
accepterons d'augmenter en quoi que ce
soit leurs salaires s'ils se sont pas
les travailleurs qui par des grèves
massives leur arrache ses d'augmentation
alors écoutez moi une entreprise c'est
un destin commun ne l'oubliez jamais et
lundi jean de l'entreprise je suis
désolé de dire il a aussi intérêt à ce
que son entreprise tourne là vous vous
êtes dans une vieille notion de lutte
des classes et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les français vous suivent pas
parce que je crois profondément qu'il
peut y avoir dans chaque entreprise
une définition et une progression
progressive cette qu'à le lire des
salaires pour permettre à l'outil qu'est
l'entreprise en soin de tourner neil je
crois que vous faites une erreur
fondamentale aujourd'hui ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il va pas y avoir des conflits
mais je crois que votre vision de lutte
ouvrière c'est à dire de lutte des
classes est largement par certains côtés
dépasser alors pardonnez moi monique
d'abord on va regarder un petit message
qui vous fera certainement plaisir trois
sondés sur quatre pense en tout cas
qu'il manuel macro on l'a dit tout à
l'heure n'a pas répondu aux attentes des
gilet jaune nous avons demandé donc cet
avis aux téléspectateurs emmanuel macron
le président des riches comme on l'a
souvent dit ou pas regardez cet avis
vers le micro et hors sol déconnecté des
réalités oui c'est le père noël des
riches suppression de l' isf du crédit
que du cic votre avis vous êtes
évidemment d'accord j'imagine avec rib
ou rip et chasser sur le père noël des
riches c'est sûr mais justement je
dirais pas qu'il est hors sol est
déconnecté des réalités parce que c'est
son boulot il est venu pour ça c'est
comme tous les autres présidents avant
lui on sait faut pas se raconter
d'histoires non plus mais mais il est là
pour ça il est là pour donner ces
milliards aux plus riches c'est c'est
pas parce que ils ignorent la situation
des pauvres gens etc même si il les
maîtrise les méprise complètement tout
le monde se rappelle de camp des petites
phrases de macron de quand il avait dit
que les gars étaient des lieux où ont
rencontré des gens qui réussissent et
des gens qui ne sent rien c'est pour
macron toute une partie de la population
ce sont des gens qui ne sont rien ça
c'est pas moi qui l'inventé c'est lui
qui l'a 10 et ses phrases à lui c'est
donc effectivement c'est le président
des riches et même des très très riches
mais
c'est en toute connaissance de cause
c'est un choix volontaire jacques myard
pourtant l'insee nous dit emmanuel
macron oui il a augmenté le pouvoir
d'achat des français notamment des plus
modestes sommes écoutés c'est
l'épaisseur du trait que le gouvenement
dijon n'a maintenu pour à l'achat compte
tenu des difficultés qu'on a eu dont
acte mais 1,6 sur 4 5 ans je dirais que
c'est l'épaisseur du trait et ce qui
n'est pas acceptable c'est effectivement
ça a été je mettrai les commentaires
méprisants qu'il a eu pour les français
et ça pour moi ça ne passe pas parce que
ce sont des hommes des femmes qui
travaillent et qu'ils doivent avoir la
dignité justement de personnes qui
travaillent et aujourd'hui quand le
gouvernement claironne qu'il a eue 1,6
pour cent d'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat je peux vous dire que même dans
les classes moyennes quand on dit ça ils
sont plus qu'étonné et vous montre la
feuille d'impôts donc ça mérite quand
même qu'on y réfléchisse deuxièmement
c'est très bien qu'il ya eu une deuxième
note une deuxième étude qui a montré que
malheureusement les plus précaires les
personnes les plus faibles avait une
perte de pouvoir d'achat donc on s'amuse
pas à faire cela parce que ça ça créé
justement je dirais le risque de haine
et le risque de la révolte ont peut-être
qu'on a réussi à maintenir aux 90 % 95 %
des français le pouvoir d'achat mais on
n'a pas à véritablement entre le
claironner car ces appels l'épaisseur du
trait alors il me voix dissonantes ce
soir dans la majorité il faut bien le
dire de nos messages télégramme celle de
michel j'ai beaucoup voyagé je suis bien
heureux d'être en france pour arrêter de
se plaindre on a quand même les à l'est
de la sécu le chômage partiel les allocs
en pleine crise sanitaire qu'est ce que
vous répondez à michel monique da ba ba
évidemment en vivant en france on n'a
pas les mêmes conditions que ceux qui
vivent
liban en afghanistan où je ne sais où
par exemple c'est ok mais mais et alors
c'est on est dans un pays où la le cac
40 la bourse a battu son record
historique la semaine dernière donc
l'argent il y en a plein le cac40 ses 60
milliards de bénéfices pour les six
premiers mois de l'année c'est ça c'est
cet argent il y en a plein c est au
contraire alors qu'on pourrait avoir
bien plus dans les services publics ça
fait des années que l'état se désengage
des services publics en vingt ans il ya
eu 100 mille lits supprimés dans les
hôpitaux c'est on va dire youpi c'est
bien tout ce qui se passe ici parce que
ça peut être pire ailleurs ben non
pourquoi voir là où c'est pire ça
pourrait être mieux ça pourrait être
mieux en prenant sur les profits qui
sont qui sont colossaux et qui sont
faits dans ce pays l'un il ya aucune
raison pour que les salariés soient à
chaque fois les ceux qui doivent payer
ce qu'ils doivent faire parce que
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat le le
chômage partiel ça quand même amputé les
salaires de 9 100 200 300 400 euros
quelquefois c'est là les travailleurs il
a fallu qu'ils continuent à vivre avec
ça et ça c'était une vraie baisse des
salaires et des revenus ça a été et
c'est pas fini parce que l'ennemi la ccc
les plus pauvres pour macron aidant les
plus pauvres voyaient les chômeurs etc
aux chômeurs qui veut s'attaquer
maintenant les pompes et en suspendant
et en supprimant les allocations s'il
n'y a pas des recherches massives
d'emplois etc donc oui le sait le
président des riches est l'ennemi des
pauvres merci en tout cas monique d'abba
merci également à jacques myard d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir et c'est la fin de